good evening ladies and gentlemen good
evening and welcome to what I hope will
be an extraordinary evening and a very
surprising evening despite it naturally
beginning on a disappointing note and
that is that Krista isn't physically
with us you'd be pleased to know that he
is actually watching this event and he
will be very pleased to hear them
with him is his wife Carol and one of
his great friends Ian McEwan the
novelist amongst his many many features
one of them is a genius for friendship
as we will discover but I'm delighted to
welcome you all to the Southbank centers
Royal Festival oh yeah
you will be I'll tell you who you'll be
hearing from and it won't surprise you
if you know anything about Christopher
you'll be hearing from Martin Amos
you'll be hearing yes the man himself
you'll be hearing from Christopher
Buckley from James Fenton from Salman
Rushdie and here in this theatre I'll be
talking to emeritus professor Richard
Dawkins
and that's very exciting at eleventh
hour edition a remarkable man a
remarkable artist remarkable actor who's
a huge huge admirer of Christopher as I
can tell everyone in this room is and
we're hoping through the joys of Google+
hangout to have a conversation with Sean
Penn so first of all I just got a few
words to say about Christopher Eric
Hitchens yes
his middle name really is Eric maybe a
comic named was now but it's a was the
name of his father and B of course was
the first name of a writer polemicist
essayist and political thinker on whom
Christopher's written a book and from
whom he can write the claim descendency
and influenced Eric Blair his pen name
of course was George Orwell you can call
Christopher hitch you might call him the
age you can addressed him as mr.
Hitchens or Christopher but if you wish
to emerge from his presence unscathed
don't even think of calling him Chris
I have to explain why it's me here why
did I here introducing this evening and
evening during which Christopher and I
was scheduled to shoot the breeze him in
in Washington DC and myself here I can't
claim to call him a friend with anything
like the depth of meaning that several
of the people were going to hear from
this evening can but I can at least
claim the privilege of having debated
with him by his side pay on why and here
in London for intelligence squared and
and I can claim to that we call each
other old horse like Stanley Ukridge or
old crumpet like Barney Phipps or oofy
prosser for we share a love and a great
passion for the works of P G Woodhouse
and such things form a bond the first
thing I want to disabuse you of is the
notion that Christopher is an earnest
and humorless political
and and after the sanctimonious figure
as his sometimes painted he has fought
for all kinds of causes all his life he
stood up against bullies his outrage
those who assumed he was a natural ally
he has poured all his energies talents
and enthusiasms in a thousand directions
but always always with wit with panache
with a sumptuously exquisite use of
language with a deep understanding that
the connection between style and
substance is absolute a true thing badly
expressed is a lie Christopher has
opened up debate given voice to ideas
and causes that without his talents
would have been less ventilated and less
understood he's done so from a position
of learning and understanding that earns
the accolade no matter how unloved and
forlorn it is in anglo-saxon nations of
intellectual like me he's Jewish on his
mother's side the side that counts like
me he's busy and productive but unlike
me he is not a cheap [ __ ] well I thank
you for that applause I say that I'm
actually quite an expensive [ __ ] and I
like to think I'm a good boy
because I kiss but I am I am way out of
Christopher's major-league almost
everybody is it's no accident that the
great associations in his life which he
was at the absolute center of one of the
most remarkable talented and tight
circle of friends in British cultural
life in the last 50 years who are all
distinguished not only by their supreme
intelligence their speed of wit their
range of learning and breadth of
knowledge but also quite simply at the
very level of the sentence by their
miraculous ability to put one word after
another in the service of poetry the
essay the novel criticism story or
political screed certainly was committed
traveller protester pamphleteer
propagandist for the far left a
Trotskyist
an international Brigadier of the old
school traveling from Cyprus to Cambodia
from Cuba to Paris Hassan wetab an
old-fashioned hard left
vulture dissident and descent sir it's
somehow Christopher has emerged
I once says the most important member of
that group would that be a meaninglessly
chief and pointless thing to say but as
a very very surprisingly influential and
important figure of our times he has
become in the words of Willy Loman
someone of a [ __ ] he's torn into sacred
cows like Mother Teresa
Princess Diana he's horrified many of
his apparently natural liberal left
allies with his attacks on Clinton his
fervent support for the war in Iraq and
he's risen to the top of many little
black books of revenge thanks to his
bravura attacks on religionists
spiritual snake oil salesmen established
churches but risen he certainly has to a
point of Fame adulation and attention
that I think has surprised no one more
than himself
so what we're here perhaps most of all
to celebrate
is that someone in this cultural desert
of celebrity worship counter
enlightenment malice and revealed
Scripture tyranny someone has shown that
there is still in this world especially
amongst the intelligent and curious
young a furious appetite for ideas for
knowledge for thought and for the
questioning of authority for being in
the word from one of his best books a
contrarian in that sense Christopher
Hitchens can read could be described as
a hero not of the left or of the neocon
right not of libertarianism or of
liberal humanism but a hero of the mind
but he's certainly my hero and thanks to
technology we will now be able to hear I
hope I very much will be able to hear
from others who would mind to and so I'm
gonna go and sit in that chair there and
pray that the might of Google has
allowed a miracle to take place so watch
me pay
mm-hmm oh look there's Sean hooray
Sean Penn welcome and thank you very
much for joining us can you hear clearly
yes a fantastic
I know it's morning in Los Angeles where
you are and as you know it's evening and
the night is closing in in London and I
know you admire Christopher Chin's
enormously and there are many many
reasons why one might and I believe I
believe that one of the reasons you
admire amis is for the extraordinary if
you like ferocity and ultimately
validated truth of his attack on one of
the most powerful men in American
history and that is Henry Kissinger is
that is that how you first came across
Christopher as a as a polemicist who
attacked Kissinger yes it was his book
the child of Henry Kissinger that really
focus my attention on his work and then
followed also by a kind of the
Magnificent magnificence of his language
was I think particularly in spiration to
those of us in America who have
undervalued it and then the clarity of
his thought I think made him a
particular particularly sharp knife in
the cutting of Kissinger who I think the
original title of the book and Chris's
mine was Henry portrait of a serial
killer that was not appreciated by
publishing but I think what Kissinger
was confronted with with the Christopher
Hitchens was somebody who was not
distracted by a the intelligence of
Kissinger or his articulation his Kris
could more than match it and had a
clarity of a kind of pure and
unencumbered morality that saw what
Kissinger's motivations were in a way
that was unequivocal yes and of course
Kissinger attempted to sue Christopher
didn't he and that we are so pleased to
see smoking by the way it is
it's it's a magnificent sight it would
be far less shocking to most audiences
if you took your penis out on stage so
congratulations for doing that and
Christopher is more than a rhetorician
he does have to do that thing and this
is one of the reasons I admire me has to
do that thing called work where you
actually have to find out facts you have
to route all around and you have to get
them right because the cost of getting
them wrong is enormous especially in
America it's a lawsuit it's a lawsuit
that can ruin you and the side of
Christopher that perhaps people don't
understand because it's the side they
naturally never see they see they see
the the famous slightly shambling
drinker and smoker who adorned so many
platforms and made so many debates and
and and what's so extraordinary in his
ability to speak perfectly without notes
was so absolutely unbeatable in debate
possibly the greatest debater since
demosthenes and what they don't see is
the man alone in his library or the man
chasing sources the man making sure that
every word he writes is not only
beautifully written but it's beautifully
researched and and that is that is why
it books like the Kissinger book still
bear reading time and time again because
they're kind of unarguable amongst the
causes for which he is known there is
one perhaps which Springs most readily
to people's lips and that is that is if
you like the he noticed before many of
us did that the tide of the
Enlightenment was being rolled back
quite deliberately and so he is very
well known for amongst other things he's
extraordinary but God is not great our
religion poisons everything and perhaps
the best-known even better known than
Christopher for such a thing is the
emeritus professor for the understanding
of science from Oxford University who
let us not forget it is one of the great
evolutionary biologists
today and I'm about to introduce him on
stage now Professor Richard Dawkins
most advanced piece of a feather
well Richard in a sense would it be fair
to say that that your anger at religion
is not so much the prime cause of your
life it's just simply did you found it
was getting in the way of a free
education of free thinking yes I think
my anger probably like Christopher's is
somewhat exaggerated and it's
exaggerated because people who are very
devoted to religion when they hear any
kind of criticism however mild they
think it's angry I think the reason is
they're so unused to it that even if
relatively mild criticism a criticism
that would sound mild if it was a
criticism of a piece of theatre or a
restaurant or something if its religion
it sounds angry so I think that's
exaggerated I mean I to the extent that
I am angry I think possibly my anger
would be slightly different from
Christopher's in that he I suppose is
angry because he sees the tyrannical God
figure as a sort of dictator a kind of
North Korea horror figure I'm sort of
guessing there whereas in my case I
think it's sort of educational I feel
that the subversion of young minds
teaching them the the second-rate
explanation for the existence of
themselves and the universe as opposed
to the real one given that the real one
is so enthralling and fascinating it's
just so tawdry and so second-rate to FOB
them off with supernaturalism so that
that to the extent that I am angry
that's probably the main source of it
yeah surprisingly I think it was Yasser
Arafat who said that the history of most
of the Wars of the world is quarrels
over who's invisible friend was more
power
I suppose you will continue to get hate
mail I know Christopher has had the
weird experience of having to decide
which is weird the the people who are
praying for him not not necessarily even
to get better but to find faith in his
moment of physical illness all those who
are gloating that he will roast for
eternity in the hell I think they're
about equal in numbers aren't they I
wonder whether when they say I'll pray
for you he gives that wonderful reply
I'll think for you brilliant we have now
someone who is of kind of great dynasty
in America his father is probably well
known as one of the most conservative
spokesmen and figures of the 50:16 70s
particularly famous for his coming to
blows with gore Vidal on many occasions
on television and his son has turned out
to be one of the great comic writers of
his time and had a bit of a falling out
with his beloved father although there
were different political persuasions he
wrote a famous essay saying something I
think it was called something like sorry
dad but I'm voting for Obama and he's a
friend of Christopher's and he's a he's
a quite quite wonderful writer in a
common theme for the evening from the
great smoker Christopher Hitchens to the
great smoker as we now know Shaun 10 we
come to the author of thank you for
smoking Christopher Buckley hello
Christopher
how are you hello Steven hello London
and hello Christopher now you know
something about the the world of
doctrinal politics in America better
than most because as I say you come from
a family and your father was that was a
very well-known very well respected also
very well feared as spokesman for the
right and his name forever coupled with
Gore Vidal's as as justing and through
the 60s and you yourself have have been
a much gentler figure but you like
Christopher and I think it's a sign that
I want to reiterate about Christopher
our comic writer and Christopher is one
of the wittiest writers in English as
well as sometimes one of the most savage
and will you agree with that absolutely
agree with that I as a footnote it was
my father who I believe gave Christopher
his first exposure on American
television and three years ago
Christopher made a heroic effort to
attend my father's funeral Mass at st.
Patrick's he flew in from Grand Rapids
Michigan I think grabbed the last seat
but then found himself in the awkward
position of being in the in the same
church as Henry Kissinger and that's one
of the other villagers at my father's
funeral mass so he he records in his
marvelous book hich 22 how he ducked out
onto the into a rain swept Fifth Avenue
to have a cigarette so that he would not
be counted as having been among Henry
Kissinger's audience I suppose part of
the part of the splendor Christopher's
life is the way he mixes
with politics and considering he was
someone of the hard left the hard left
were always were always taken to be
those figures who could weep for the
masses but had no ability as it were to
care for individuals where he was never
like that do you think there is a word
for Christopher's politics well that
they Christopher when I first knew him
in the early 80s when he came down to
Washington and to cover the Falklands
crisis I was working for as a
speechwriter for George Herbert Walker
Bush or the good Bush over there and
Christopher at that time was a very hard
leftist he wrote for all the all the the
very left-wing publications he was a
correspondent for the nation and but he
has such a supple and with the bow to
Professor Dawkins if I may use the term
evolutionary mind that he made a rather
interesting trajectory through the years
so that he he he became in the early
part of the last decade of the last
century one of the one of the great
proponents of US military invention in
Iraq it's been it's it's been it's been
quite a quite a quite a spectacle to
watch but Christopher has has never no
one who would ever accuse him of having
been dull he is usually well if I may
say he Christopher was the Rick Blaine
of Washington I refer of course to the
Humphrey Bogart character in the movie
Casablanca everyone went to the hitches
he famously in the I guess it was the
first years of the Clinton
administration threw a party at his flat
in Washington for after the White House
Correspondents Dinner and it became the
it was the Vanity Fair party and
everyone came and it got so big after
two or three years that it had to move
to a rather interesting venue write it
directly across the street the Russian
Trade Federation
which was an odd place to have a Rick's
Cafe but you I I mean everyone came I on
one memorable memorable occasion I I got
to Barbra Streisand caught fire
quite literally by standing a little bit
too close to a to a candle and she
really the world was on the verge of
losing Barbra Streisand miss Parsons
politics in my own are very divergent or
perhaps discrepant to use a hit hit
Chuncheon word but I was I was one of
the first responders in the bhindi
Barbra Streisand self-immolation you
know that's my little footnote in
history
we have many other reasons too Thank You
Christopher but it's been extremely
enjoyable and and thank you for taking
the time and bless you and bye-bye thank
you very much
now give me one I do my best to check to
see um without giving away too many
secrets you know how how technically
advanced Christopher and his wife are by
the fact that they both have an AOL
address
I know it's just talked about it's like
Lady Bracknell the unfashionable side of
the square I tried to persuade blues
Carol Carol who's his wife to see if she
could use an instant messaging system
that they don't seem too immense to do
that she did say you might even try and
text me so I'm assuming we've got any
words of wisdom yet from here on my
thing yes oh yes that she's chosen email
which is really good we've got we've got
contributions yes that the games begin
it starts and these are being typed by
Ian McEwan because apparently his
fingers are better so and this is from
he and I talked until late last night
with it we were discussing the
non-communist left of the early 50s
you can't run a mile just now but be
reassured the world's ROIs mind is
purring smoothly which is a very good
line there from Ian McEwan now I'm going
to introduce someone who I've admired
and I wish I could say I knew I know him
through his poetry I think we are lucky
to be living in a time when there are
still great poet Seamus Heaney is still
with us and I do believe that the
greatest English poet alive is James
Fenton he is simply remarkable if you
don't know his work is the most it's as
accessible as Philip Larkin as deep as
Eliot or any poet you wish it to be it's
as long-lasting and as refreshing to the
mind as purcha can be it is absolutely
perfect
he has been one of Christopher's closest
friends for the longest possible time
since their Oxford days as
undergraduates and he is in New York so
we want to say hello if we can
- James Fenton hello
James I've spoken a little about the
extraordinary sodality the the group
that you form with Martin and Ian and
drive James and Salman and Christopher a
group of friends have stayed together in
a way that is really quite extraordinary
inspiring I wish I could say I knew
anyone in my generation who had an
equivalent and it's not only the
strength of your friendship it is also
the quite astounding depth of all of
your individual talents when this
evening was planned and create and
Christopher knew that he wasn't going to
be able to take part one of the things
that he was very excited about was the
possibility of you reading a poem and I
know we all love to hear that and yes
which one have you chosen and you
suggested it as the skip the skip which
was my favorite he's the one that
Christopher suggested good we'd love to
hear it
well then I'll read it and I just say
before I do so what I always say in
America I know that I'm talking to you
in England but in America we say that a
skip is a dumpster the skip I I took my
life and threw it on the skip reckoning
the next-door neighbors wouldn't mind if
my life hitched a lift to the council
tip with their dry rotten rubble what
you find with skips is the whole
community joins in old mattresses appear
doors kind of drift along with all that
won't fit in the bin and stuff the
binman can't be fished to shift I throw
away my life and there it lay and grew
quite sudden what a dreadful shame
clucked some old bag and sucked her
teeth the way the young these days no
values me I blame but I blamed no one
quality control had Loused it up and
that was that nuff said I couldn't
stick at home I took a stroll and passed
the skip and left my life for dead
without my life the beer with justice
foul the landlord still as filthy as his
wife the chicken in the basket was an
owl and no one said he Jem lad Worth Lee
life well I got back that night the
worse for wear but still just capable of
single vision looked in the skip my life
it wasn't there some buggered nicked it
without my permission okay so I got
angry and began to shout and woke the
street okay okay and I was sick all down
the neighbours van and I disgraced
myself on the parkade and then you know
how if you've had a few your wake at
dawn all healthy like sea breezes raring
to go and thinking clever you you got
away with it and then oh Jesus it hits
you well that morning just at 6:00
I woke got up and looked down at the
skip there lay my life still sodden on
the bricks they're lame a poor old life
ass overtip or was it mine still dressed
I went downstairs and took a long cool
look the truth was dawning someone had
just exchanged my life for theirs poor
fool I thought I should have left a
warning some bastard saw my life and
thought it nicer than what he'd had yet
what he'd had seemed fine he never
caught his fingers in the slicer the way
I'd managed with that life of mine his
life lay glistening in the rain
neglected but still a decent an
authentic life some people I can think
of I reflected would take that thing as
soon as you'd say knife
it seemed a shame to miss a chance like
that
I brought the life in dried it by the
stove
it looked so fetching stretched out on
the mat I tried it on it fitted like a
glove and now when some local bat drops
off the twig a new folk take the house
and pull up floors and knock down walls
and hire some kind of big container say
a skip for their old doors I'll watch it
like a hawk and everyday I make at least
Oh half a dozen trips I've furnished an
existence in that way you'd not believe
the things you find on skips
thank you very much Jen Fenton
the wonderful games Benjamin thank you
very much thank you
now the person we're next going to speak
to is in my opinion aside from being a
really great writer
I think his place in Christopher's life
may be an explanation for some of the
some of the ways that Christopher's
politics changed and and that is the man
he defended so brilliantly when quite
uncle is shamefully so many on the Left
refused to come forward and defend him
and that is the man who for years had to
hide with a threat of death on him for
writing a book a book which if you
haven't gone back to reread it he's a
marvelous marvelous novel he continues
to write marvelous novels he continues
to be the one only Salman Rushdie
hello Salma
it's wonderful to see you here there's a
as not making this an Oxford and
Cambridge fight because of course
Christian was both having gone to school
in Cambridge in them University in
Oxford but there's a Cambridge tradition
which is very marked by the hard left
which might be said to be represented by
the philosopher GE Moore and by the
Bloomsbury group and and in particular
by the writer e/m Forster and that is
the count of personal relations and
there's a famous line of foresters which
is if you came to a choice between
betraying my friend or betraying my
country I hope I would have the guts to
betray my country
and that if you like was the starting
point of that culture personal relations
as you know and I've often wondered that
if the Satanic Verses
had been written by someone who wasn't
an incredibly close friend of
Christopher do you think he would have
been activated in quite the way he was
in other words was your friendship a
part of you know a part of the proof
that he wasn't all hard left that there
was a part of him that was also just a
little bit Bloomsbury you know I think
probably he'd have reacted exactly the
same way because I think what what got
up his nose was the idea that you know
an aging prelate in an in an antique
land could sentence to death
a writer across the world for the crime
of writing a book I think he just was
something he couldn't countenance and
but I do think that what happened then
was that his friendship with me drove
him to become the most extraordinary
ally and help her in those hard times I
mean I remember when after many years or
many when a very long period of effort
we managed to arrange partly with
Christopher's help a meeting with
President Clinton actually was staggered
Christopher's house left from
to his house to go to the meeting which
was on the day before Thanksgiving and
on the day before Thanksgiving the
president the United States always has
to ceremonially pardon a turkey one
turkey Tom the turkey is pardoned all
the others are killed yeah I was going
to be seeing Clinton immediately before
the pardoning of the turkey and so we
imagined the possible headline of the
newspapers the next day which was which
was at Clinton pardons Turkey University
gets stuffed however as it happens the
meeting was quite successful and I
remembered that George Stephanopoulos
then an aide of Clinton's who had been
very helpful was so excited when the
meeting took place that he called
Christopher at his house and said the
eagle has landed so Christopher was very
very much at the heart of that struggle
and I've always been I've been grateful
to him is understating what I feel and
also his fury was not just towards
towards as you rightly say an aging
cleric in an antique land but also
towards quite a startling number of
writers in Britain and America who were
very blacks in coming forward in what
seems to me so clear-cut a case there
were people who said I've read the book
and don't think it's very good as if
that might be a reason why you should be
killed there were there were others who
said that because you were yourself have
a left left inclination it was an
outrage that the police should defend
you and I think it was as much his fury
the lack of defense from others as as
from the fact where itself is that a
fair analysis yeah I think that's I
think that so I've been from for me that
just the main memory of those years is
that is that Christopher was always
there when I needed him you know one of
the things I learned in those years is
that is the meaning of a friend in need
you know and Christopher was a you know
transcendent example of that he
was therefore whenever I needed him for
whatever I needed him for and if we
thought he was just to do both with his
principles and the way in which he felt
those principles were offended by the
attack on on my book but also by his you
know as we know from his memoir his
enormous gift for personal friendship
exactly and I was gonna returned his
memoir hich 22 when he first as it were
introduces you it might come as surprise
to those who don't have the privilege of
knowing you that what almost the first
thing that impressed you had pressed him
about you with your facility with words
and the fun and games you had with words
can you take us through some of those
some of your particular games are used
well
well Christopher you know is a very
funny man and we did invent one or two
sort of ridiculous word games well the
perhaps of what I could share with you
is the one about titles that don't quite
make it and examples of this would be a
farewell to weapons for whom the bell
rings mr. Vargo to kill a havoc to to
kill a hummingbird the catcher in the
catcher in the wheat Melville's great
masterpiece
Toby dick
etc this is it
these were games that we played Martin
had a Marty but he had a more obscene
game but there was hit there well there
was the game about hysterical sex where
you replaced the word love in the titles
of things with the phrase hysterical sex
that gives you hysterical sex in the
Time of Cholera hysterical sex is a
many-splendored thing all you need is
hysterical sake and so on fun to be had
it is that all those people those young
people I mean not one not one of them a
leader in their in their field novelists
and I'll of those word games and another
one that I remember they played was to
substitute the word dick for heart so my
dick is like a red red rose will you be
my sweetie
I think I hope straight away to the
center of the sodality at least
according to James Fenton and that is
one of the great novelists of our times
also a great assess of our times and of
course one Christopher's greatest
friends Martin Amos are you there margin
hello
you stayed friends throughout a long
period of history and in which you all
became such extraordinary successful
people and that just two years ago there
was an exhibition of photographs because
you were engaged
for a few years - and - the Gorgas the
photographer who was a friend of you all
I think we've got some of the pictures
from the National Portrait Gallery acts
exhibition here here's one with Angela
and hitch in this photograph we see
Angela Gorgas living up to her nickname
of Angela
sorry gorgeous - looking handsomer than
any man has the right to be with a
baguette in his top pocket instead of
her the next picture is called hitch and
his is a portrait I think and there he
is absurdly handsome and the hair on his
chest is actually grown up to his throat
that you could have a long lunch with
hitch which would turn into a long
dinner and then as you went to bed at 4
o'clock in the morning reconciled to a
hangover that would last a half a week
you'd wake up and with a groan 12 hours
late and find that hitch had written to
3,000 work pieces about John Locke and
John Stuart Mill this was one of the
most galling things about him he could
hold his drink and sometimes he'd stay
up all night and then go into a TV
program with Germaine Greer and Norman
Mailer but it wasn't on that occasion
that he staggered up to Norman Mailer
and in his own description stinking
drunk he was pitch
he said he lurched and burping up to
Norman Mailer and said I read that
interview where you said that that I am
Martin eNOS and Ian Hamilton former
homosexual cleek in the London literary
world and he said and I just want you to
know that I think that's very unfair to
Ian Hamilton
and birthing off thinking that didn't
turn out quite as I wanted it well of
course there is there is the eternal
mystery which will join the mysteries
that Thomas Brown mentioned in you know
that we will never know what to name
Achilles took when he went among women
and we will never know the song the
siren sang and we will never know the
names of the two men in the Conservative
government whom Hitchens bedded when he
was a young undergraduate but I I don't
expect you to give the game away but
it's an intriguing game that will be
played forever but you can see why they
bedded him because he was a rather a
beauty and the other picture here again
with cigarette but most surprisingly
with a brace of business and it's
entitled of all things hitch on the
Rothschild estate we we agreed that the
idea that the Bollinger Bolshevik was
inherently hypocritical had to be kicked
out why should why should only
right-wing people be able to enjoy
champagne and Christopher very much real
ished the high and the low but I would
like to tell this little story about I
think shows how he felt about class we
were in a restaurant a tiny restaurant
there were two elegant decadent young
men interminably and unag Nora bleah
badgering the staff to have rearranged
the tables to so that they could
accommodate the large party they
accepted we were middle bohemian they
were minor gentry I would say and they
had that that look of those of people
who who await with epic calm the deaths
of elderly relatives and one of these
young men came up and just swooped
swooped down in an elegant crouch in
front of Christopher and me and he's
obviously going to ask us to move tables
and he pout it up through his fringe and
said after a flirtatious pause you're
going to hate
for this the Christmas said we hate you
already wonderful you two have joined us
not in any thank you very much
I want to end by thanking all the
contributors from around from Los
Angeles our short glimpse of Sean Penn
and his cigarette and and and all of
Christopher's friends for Richard who
took a train from Sheffield I believe
where you were just to be here tonight
and for all of you for coming even
though you knew that the real hero was
not going to be present I did speak to
him on the telephone before I came on
stage his voice was hoarse but excited
he is thrilled that this evening
happened and I know that on behalf of
him and his wife he would want me to
thank you all very warmly for coming and
for allowing us to have it's not really
the kind of thing I do very well this
kind of television presentation and
speaking to delayed satellites but
you've all been unbelievably kind and
supportive and thank you very much
indeed all I can say about
you